so welcome back to another Journal this
is my July Journal slash vlog slash
dying format that doesn't get the views
that movie reviews do but I don't care
because it's fun to do I'm at least
gonna do it through the year so we'll
have a year chronicling my life and
these are generally the events I will
say LG hit me up in July and they were
like hey we have this new 4k ultra
high-def high dynamic range short throw
projector do you want it we'll give it
to you you put it in your journal entry
I was like okay so we tried to get the
ink dry so I could get it in July so you
know just like will it happen in July
and it's in the July Journal but it
didn't quite work out that way I
actually ended up getting it in August
but they did still send me a projector
and so I was like I don't want to tell
them whenever wait till August you know
I don't want to be an [ __ ] about it
so at the end of this video
I dunno take it out and you know put it
through the test Oh a little bit of a
test
oh he's elbow this thing but I just want
to be transparent be like no it happened
in August but you know I don't want to
be a dick about it
however let's jump into the month of
July before we get to the projector part
in August which is also in this July
Journal puppy transition as always we're
going into the power of heard Oh more
stretchy little dome all right I just
came across some information I guess I I
must inform the people so gets hot toys
that was gypsy so I guess hot toys is
coming out with another two-faced figure
and that'll be Ghanim gypsy
fourth-of-july gaming couple of scaredy
cats and myself they do not like
fireworks
I watched Lord of the Rings Fellowship
of the Ring tonight and then movies is
so great it's timeless it's like a fine
wine it just gets better and better with
a just like as I aged and watch Lord of
the Rings I see I view Lord of the Rings
differently I just kind of take it all
in differently as I just grow and mature
and just get life experience it's like
that's how it's been ever since it came
out to now it's just like I'm like oh I
didn't notice that before I didn't know
stuff before I see that kind of
differently because growth is growth
that's the mark of a movie that's truly
timeless you know it's so good and also
I just noticed this is one of the things
I just i sized it up with movies today
not all movies today but a lot of movies
today that scene with all running from
the uruk-hai at the end and merry and
pippin
get their attention like hey over here
to get them away from Frodo and they're
running and they go it's working I know
it's working run and it's a funny line
it's a funny moment but that humor
didn't compromise the tension of the
moment because the moment was still
intense it's not like the movie just
felt like he'd ground to a halt or the
tension hit a brick walls like oh no
it's a funny scene so it's not actually
intense a lot of movies don't seem to
hit that bullseye Lord of the Rings does
this is so good got 100% the power of
Instagram the power of the fans strikes
again because I put pictures of the
castle I was like I can't find it can
anyone help this one dude was like yeah
you're missing this one so I did it I
got up to 99.9% he was like and you're
missing this other one thanks dude
seriously I don't know how I did this
kind of [ __ ] when I was a kid in fact
like I wasn't the one in the family did
my brother was the one he's like I'm
going to 100% everything in Symphony of
the Night me I was like a couple of
things can slide
man he good dude get a kick out of this
get he nice play super late at night
it's like 1:45 in the morning I'm
watching stranger things season 3 and it
just got dawned on me as I saw a comment
in the comment section of my spider-man
far from home review and this one
commenter said that he saw it with
people who didn't know spider-man Laura
they don't know who Mysterio is they
were legit surprise
there are people out there like I didn't
know that actually really envy them
watching that movie these are the deep
things I think about it 145 in the
morning while watching strangers hanging
season 3 so at 7:30 at 7:45 ish but it
be blood-stained II got my platinum in
the morning because I beat it and I
guess there's a missable trophy so the
only trophy I needed was this one so I
had a New Game+ it and then go all the
way to the point where you get the sword
you're supposed to slice the moon
instead of slicing the moon you kill G
Bowl and then you get the you get the
trophy I didn't know there was any how
so that's what I've been doing now am I
go to bed okay so here's what happened
here's my blood stain story so I did the
crowdfunding for blood stained I picked
the switch as the system because which
does cool little system and regardless
of what I say in this story the switch
is still a really cool system but the
switch port was just plagued with
graphical issues and latency issues had
a lot of lag ended up googling it I was
like switched port blood stain problems
and a lot of other people knows the same
things I noticed and life is too short
to play crappy ports of great games so
got the ps4 version a hundred times
better the game looks better the frame
rates better it's it's cleaner it's
smoother the graphics are more detail
that makes it it makes a switch version
look like it plays in 720 on the TV know
if it does but I swear to God compared
to the ps4 it's what it looks like so
you have two that it was a completely
different experience it actually is a
great game so a ps4 that's the version
again by this time I don't know maybe
they've patched the switch version I do
not know but it shouldn't have been
released like that it's just compared to
the other ones I've been people who cut
the switch versions just got bummed
unless they want to fork out more money
on Amazon to get it which is what I did
I'm not saying it's a smart way life's
too short to play crappy parts of great
games I'm just saying editing my
stranger things season 3 review
and I just didn't dig season three you
know today is a very special day today
marks the 10-year anniversary of my
first YouTube movie review Transformers
Revenge of the Fallen ten years of
reviewing movies on YouTube holy [ __ ]
you know the thing is I don't really
know what to do you know like I want to
make a video do I make it as a thanks
for the past ten years video do I make
it as a hey here's what I would have
done differently video on the course of
my YouTube adventures I don't know
okay so just had therapy today was
therapy day I was at 8 a.m. there's an
early one and I am a night owl I love
sleeping in I love staying up late o
staying up late and then really sleep in
the [ __ ] but it was at 8 a.m. and I
found out actually I learned this years
ago I'm telling you this now that the
key to being a night owl and making an
early appointment like an 8:00 a.m.
appointment is simply not going to sleep
now I should probably go home and go to
sleep
alright so stranger things season 3 so I
have read the comments in the comment
section and I'll tell you this there's a
coolness in there that I really like
because it takes it back to early
YouTube for me there are people in the
comments section of my stranger thing
season 3 review who were like dude thank
you for saying this oh my god I thought
I was alone I didn't like the season
either granted a lot of people who are
like you're [ __ ] crazy um but I like
those messages I don't like all feedback
but I like I really connect with those
messages with people like oh my god I
thought I was alone I didn't know my
friends see it this way like they all
loved it I didn't really like it my
channel was just built on connecting
with my fellow misfits out there I don't
know it's kind of deep in my head about
it it was kind of cool it took me back
to uh took me back to the point like the
reason I started my youtube channel I
was I was a cool moment about to watch
The Lion King to 10:00 a.m. screening in
Seattle but tinfoil hat on it I just
learned that never ending story is on
Netflix
and stranger things is a Netflix show
his change of things season three they
sing the neverending story song she was
a cross-promotion how many more people
watched neverending story on Netflix
because they sang this song and stranger
things season 3 I'm just saying we're
shopping for shirts suits and ties point
is I'm bringing the jackets back in the
videos I'm inspired
I got bows sunglasses that play music
like directly into my skull it's pretty
awesome actually danger likes it don't
you danger the birthday of these two
little shits
it's July 12 happy birthday danger
almost sleep patterns are really 5 yeah
went to bed at like 10 and I was like
alright I'm in bed for the night danger
just jumped up here but uh then I woke
up at like 1:30 in the morning I'm like
I feel like I'm up so I'm gonna play
some destiny too I saw I just finished
watching Return of the King extended
edition which means I just finished
watching the Lord of the Rings trilogy
for the umpteenth time and it just gets
better and better like it really like
this text my friends afterwards I was
like so I'm crushed beyond repair in the
most satisfied way possible there's the
only way I can describe it now I know I
always kind of go back before it kind of
always but I have always gone back and
forth between which do I like better
Return of the King or Fellowship of the
Ring and after this time I feel like I'm
drawing a hard line and saying
Fellowship of the Ring it just it's the
introduction to the lore the characters
the fellowship the world Return of the
King is great but it's great because the
trilogy is great like it's a satisfying
conclusion what is Return of the King
without the rest of the trilogy about
fellowship I can just watch a hundred
times over back to back to back but this
is why I don't like that monologue just
happen to my phone is why I just
consider Lord of the Rings one movie you
know like the trilogy is just one epic
12 hour long movie this headache is
business should be editing my June
journal I really should flash
marathon I kind of fell off the flash
wagon I'm watching season four I really
liked the villa I like the fact that
it's not a speedster it's a really smart
person just crossed my mind and tell me
what you think of this I'm pretty sure
Batman vs Superman is the first Batman
movie to not have a Batman love interest
like some flirting with Wonder Woman
here and there but no active Batman love
interest I don't know you want to do
with that information but just dawned on
me are we're never gonna address how
brave it was a Vader to face obi-wan
Kenobi like last time
Vader saw obi-wan Kenobi obi-wan turned
him into a quadriplegic and on the Death
Star he sensed Obi Wan's presence anyone
else would have just run from that
scenario but not Vader Vader faced his
fear we're never gonna touch on how
brave that was enough you know today is
its one year since Jon Schnepp passed
away and this is a story I feel like
you'd never know if I didn't tell you so
I'm totally gonna tell you this because
I love that we would do this so on comic
book shopping the segment on awesome
tacular that Schnepp and I did for it
it's basically he would inform me about
comic books like legitimately I mean the
guy who a compendium of comic book
knowledge but for every episode it was
us walking down the street and going
into the store right and so we would it
would just be like yeah walk and talk
but there was no audio ever and so he
and I would just walk and it'd be like
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
and he'd be like blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah we would just blah blah
blah scramble scramble and we would just
say nonsense because it just didn't
matter and it was just funny to us
we're just saying nothing and it looks
like we're just having these deep
conversations back that's sometimes we
would do that be like snap until it
looks like we're having a deep
conversation right now about comic books
we're really we're talking about Jack
[ __ ] he'll be like that's right Jeremy
we are talking
about jack-shit we're talking it was
just it was just for me because it's the
illusion of production you know so when
you watch that actually I don't even
know if they used a lot of the footage
but I'm pretty sure the footage of us
coming around the corner and opening the
door it totally looks like we're having
a conversation and engaging conversation
about comic books but we are
legitimately purposely using blah blah
blah or just talking about how we're
talking about absolutely nothing I was
just funny it's just like we did it for
every episode anyhow
undeniably the world was just a better
place with him in it that goes without
say that self-evident and I miss the
dude you know but I have memories that's
important you know like people live on
with what they leave behind memories are
a huge part of that so I'm glad I have
the memories with the dude and I keep
them I keep him here that I keep the
memories yep he oversees my nerd lair
daily but no serious note you never do
now
it's just hug your loved ones he was
gone way too soon she's way too young to
be God all right so I turn on YouTube I
just log into YouTube and my life and
gaming they're streaming they're doing a
live stream of an arcade playthrough of
carnivals like I just want to see
someone possibly beat this thing it's
like the impossible game anyhow I've
been watching them and if if you like
retro games and you're into the retro
gaming scene subscribe to my life and
gaming that said I really hope he beats
Caron off man
it's it's gonna be an uphill climb holy
[ __ ]
here comes Prince Caspian was Billy
Russo from The Punisher what the [ __ ]
ok so I love game bound video games and
then had to relocate so I was without
game bound video games but like now he's
got a bunch of legit real estate and I'm
gonna be here for the next four hours
sorry
also dudes a fan I didn't know that
I'm he's a customer he had no idea I'm
gonna buy a lot all right so I picked up
a Samsung video monitor so I got GBA
games through the GBA player on the
gamecube with extremes homebrew software
because it's much better than the actual
official Nintendo stuff got an adapter
so I can play it with a Super Nintendo
controller and the game looks pretty
[ __ ] slave right night trap VHS so
YouTube for some odd reason processed my
new video the zombie land 2 trailer
video at like 360 just you know just
basic standard [ __ ] 2019 I'm watching
episodes of Batman the Animated Series
which is the greatest animated series of
all time like some of these episodes are
really deep I just finished that island
of dr. Moreau ish episode man there's
some deep emotional things what this
animation is H like wine so my
collector's edition of Fire Emblem for
the switch came today I got the package
and I hope it's okay thanks ups and I
still the case though that's pretty I
like to steal the case I have to switch
steelbook cases this is one you want I
guess the next one you know the next one
you think I know the art of Fire Emblem
three houses sweet this is why we get
special editions god my hair it's doing
this thing they're just full code and
this is actually why I get these
soundtracks I just I love video game
soundtracks so 2020 calendar that's kind
of man oh wait what's my month everyone
has to see what character a monster they
get for their month right that's my
month gonna be real there's a game crush
going on right now
I mean my god also it's 8:15 in the
morning I haven't slept because fire
rainbow
Fire Emblem three houses I just finished
this fight there's skin of my teeth all
right sweet we raided the castle then
the dude turned into a big monster and I
had to fight that and I was like if one
of my characters dies I'm resetting this
this might be the time I don't finish
Fire Emblem my hair says it all I beat
him though and no one died god I'm so
scared so I the boss of a dungeon and
Fire Emblem just crits me in one hit my
main guy dies and now it's game over the
whole dungeon means nothing Fire Emblem
gypsies happier than at least you get to
keep your XP there is that it's the last
day of July the 31st I'm pretty sure I
have insomnia and I'm not even [ __ ]
with you I it's 12:20 5:00 in the
afternoon I didn't sleep last night I
stay up until 6:00 in the morning cuz
Fire Emblem three houses just got its
claws on me this is old school video
game induced in some Nia it's
captivating it's Harry Potter it's
really good
you should play it if you don't value
sleep cuz you'll stop doing that I don't
even care to sleep it's not this like
it's not like it's noon and I'm tired
I'm not tired o guardian moon time to
play so that's it generally speaking
those were the goings on for the month
of July and as promised at the end here
now I'm gonna mess with a projector that
LG sent me and I guess I want to be
clear about that because when companies
send you things for free on YouTube you
have to be so transparent about it to
the point of almost being obnoxious
about it
LG sent this projector to me at no cost
to me they sent it to me for free they
were literally like hey you're a movie
guy you want a new movie thing
you wonder projector and I was like yeah
cuz why wouldn't I like why wouldn't I
so I just want to be completely clear
about that so you know but yeah let's
check that thing out feel like I should
get close like hi how are you you come
here often so this is actually the shelf
it's on was an IKEA bookshelf cube that
I had a spare one of and so I was like
it was too tall to put the projector on
because it's a short throw projector and
the screens actually quite big it's a
it's a hundred and thirty inch screen
which the specs on this projector say it
throws up to 120 inches so I'm actually
kind of breaking the rules and having it
throw ten inches larger than what LG
considers optimal but like if this is an
optimal no man because uh yeah it's it I
mean we'll just show you so this is my
home theater room with the short throw
projector right there it actually is I
like the fact that it's like this little
compact thing I suppose I could get a
longer table or something but I'm
totally fine with it I do like the fact
all right we're gonna get down here
again like it's a really modern design
like I like the design of it which you
can tell they designed it to go into a
living room which I I'm going for
practicality here some cinema quality so
it stays here in the theater room for me
but if you wanted to have this in your
living room in your TV room and just
throw it onto a screen on your wall it
wouldn't look weird it wouldn't look
like way this is clearly a projector it
just looks like it's kind of a modern
table piece which people will ask what
is that and you'll say it's a projector
and then they'll know it's a projector
and they'll be green with envy is how it
goes here we go this is more not
copyrighted stock footage that they gave
me so I can show you but the lights are
on in the room like that's the big thing
right here it's a fact that the lights
are on I shouldn't I should barely see
an image with a projector with the
lights on and that's I'm cheating even
yes the screens 10 inches
bigger than what LG considers optimal so
you know the smaller the image the more
condensed the light the brighter the
image you get it and there it is I mean
you can't see the 4k because this camera
which we may or may not call my phone
doesn't film in 4k but it's the pictures
pop it's the contrast those deep blacks
it's like cinema black is the white
whale for home movie theater
entertainment hey like I said like any
light on the projector is from the
screen itself but the projector itself
is you wouldn't know what's on if there
wasn't something on the screen so I took
the blackout curtains down granted the
blinds are still closed so it's the
effect of having curtains but not
blackout curtains a little washed out on
the sides but still doable but I'd still
prefer the dedicated dark theater room
and granted all this footage is very
bright keep that in mind too like if I'm
watching the matrix in these conditions
I don't imagine it's gonna look too good
because it's a very dark movie so here
it is the blackout curtains are down the
blinds are open and this is the breaking
point like I wouldn't watch it like this
it's just way too washed out it's an
impressive piece of tech it's a really
bright image from the projector but it
can't contest with the full might of the
Sun so impressively you can watch this
in the daytime with the curtains or
blinds closed and they don't have to be
black out curtains that's really
impressive or you can have the lights on
in the room surprisingly I didn't expect
that but for me personally you know me
I'm always going the dedicated movie
theater dark room at the blackout
curtains because nothing beats that and
the image is just better it's just
science I will say all right first of
all there's no discernible order to the
blu-rays behind me so don't even try
it's just gonna hurt your brain but for
me I mean I blame my dad for all this to
be honest with you if there's one person
I could blame it'd be my dad like with
love love you dad but when I was a kid
he had you know the surround sound
speakers and for the analog CRTs you did
a really good job like watch movies he'd
be there with with the processor he'd be
there for all the speakers and I just
elbowed myself my room
remember him having like discussions if
not arguments if not just him getting
frustrated the fact that he would always
try to explain to people that widescreen
isn't cutting anything off of the top
and bottom you're actually getting
things cut off of the sides when you
have a full screen movie on a four by
three screen on a CRT TV and so I were
just back then it wasn't a common thing
that a lot of people knew and so I
drilled that into my mind when I was
young he was like no no you know that
now so always carry that with you now
wide screens just the standard but back
then it wasn't so it was it was only
inevitable when I had my own place that
I mean I would have a cedar room it was
actually the selling point of this house
I think this rooms supposed to be for
like kids to play in or something you
screw that noise no it's the theater
room so I'm really happy with it you
know I feel bad that I can't show you
some of the really cool things I've seen
now like I've had this thing for a
couple days and two movies that I popped
in that I actually do own unforgettable
that right there it stops there these
from here over those are the 4k movies
that I own and I have to expand my
library but I popped in the matrix and
Bladerunner 2049 and they both look it's
next level it's like the first time you
ever saw the matrix like on board this
actually streams Netflix and so just the
first thing I did before I even had the
sound hooked up was like whatever just
go see some some video and I popped on
Blue Planet 2 which is shot in 4k and
it's like I would say it's like looking
out a window it's like you're there it's
mind-blowing ly amazing but seriously I
really appreciate the projector they
didn't have to do that it was awesome so
thank you for that and you you've given
it to a good home I will give it a lot
of use and it will not go wasted I just
got to expand my library now I thank you
all for watching these still I mean
these journal videos don't get the views
that movie reviews do but it's fun you
know I feel like it's a way to connect
you guys more and I feel like people who
really give a [ __ ] watch these I hope
you know a projector in here doesn't
feel too like all sponsored or
commercial but I mean I've unboxed
things in these journals before so it's
just kind of like that just so happens I
love projector tech and it all comes
from being a projectionist years of
being a projectionists so yeah that's
kind of like a kid in a candy store
oh I hope you enjoyed it too
but maybe got a little long-winded I
hope not I hope you guys so suggestions
fellow audio video files out there if
you have any suggestions for 4k movies
high dynamic range movies that I should
get let me know what they are please
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more I should still transition with
a puppy
[Music]